لم ينخفض ​​معدل البطالة
بالقدر الذي يرتفع فيه الناس كما
يعتقد البعض جزئيًا كما يقول بعض الناس
لأنه ليس لدينا الكثير من
المهاجرين القادمين إلى البلاد.
هل تعتقد أن
الهجرة هي مشكلة من حيث
منحنا المزيد من العمالة أه العمال أو
تعتقد أن هذا ليس عاملاً ، لذا
كمسألة حسابية ، فقد
كان عاملاً لأنه كان هناك
القليل جدًا من الهجرة عبر الحدود أثناء
الوباء وكان ذلك جزءًا  مما
كان يحدث بشكل خاص في
قطاعات معينة مثل
القطاع الزراعي وخدمة الطعام وأشياء من هذا القبيل
حيث لم يكن هناك أشخاص ،
ولكن في الآونة الأخيرة فقط
ظهرت بيانات الهجرة
مرة أخرى وهكذا وأعتقد أن ذلك قد  أن تكون
جزءًا من سبب شعور الناس
بضغوط أقل إلى حد ما في سوق العمل للعثور على
عمال ، فهذه مشكلة ليست
للريش ، فهذه الهجرة من الواضح أنها
قضية سياسية ولا نسعى لأن نكون
لاعبين في هذا الأمر ، لكنها مجرد حقيقة
على الرغم من أن ذلك  أن
الولايات المتحدة لديها عدد أقل من
العمال المتاحين مقارنة بفرص العمل الخاصة بها